في الماء كليوباترا المنتج من يواجه
القضاء الاداري المصري وسبب دعوته طالب
المنصه الشهيره بدفع اثنين مليار دولار
كتعويض المحامي المصري عمرو عبد السلام
اقام دعوه قضائيه مطالبا بوقف عرض الفيلم
والتعويض عنه ايضا عبد السلام دعا لالزام
السلطات المصريه باتخاذ الخطوات القانونيه
والدبلوماسيه ضد نتفليكس بسبب الفيلم
المثير للجدل هذه دعوات تتهم صناع الفيلم
بتزييف التاريخ والاعتداء على التراث
المصري الحضري والثقافي وتزوير الهويه
المصريه القديمه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات